novembre 2020 Donald Trump digère mal sa
défaite électorale le soir même il crie
à la fraude et s'autoproclame vainqueur
oui
bon évidemment on a souvent par la
démission de cette thèse absolument non
fondée sur la fraude électorale massive
aux États-Unis maintes maintes fois
démenti bien entendu mais il y a du
nouveau dans ce dossier et cet élément
nouveau nous provient d'une poursuite
intentée contre le réseau américain Fox
News qui nous révèle ce qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est tramé en coulée c'est
Nicolas d'où ça part se retournons au
début on se souvient à cette époque-là
le président Trump beaucoup de ses
proches ont crié à la fraude électorale
à la suite de l'élection et un des
éléments des informations là-dedans qui
revenait très souvent c'était que les
fameuses machines de vote là et la
chaîne qui compte les voix des gens
étaient truqués en faveur du Parti
démocrate des informations absolument
sans fondement mais qui ont été relayés
par des invités à de multiples reprises
sur les ondes de Fox News et même par
certaines animateurs vedettes de cette
citation là il y a deux fabricants de
ces machines de votes qui poursuivent
Fox News pour diffamation et d'abord
dominer un nouveau link system ce qui
est poursuit en diffamation pour 1,6
milliards de dollars et aussi une autre
entreprise qui est poursuit en
diffamation pour 2,3 milliards de
dollars donc c'est grâce à la poursuite
de Dominion qu'on a accès à ces
documents à ces textos entre
personnalités de Fuck You bien sûr
caviaret parce qu'avant ce procès il y a
une phase lors de laquelle Dominion a pu
accumuler des preuves contrefox news de
manière tout à fait légale donc qui ont
accès à des textos à des discussions
entre des dirigeants de foxus des
animateurs la raison pour cette
poursuite je vais mentionné c'est la
diffamation ce que veut prouver de
manière avec ça c'est que Fox News a
menti intentionnellement en pleine
connaissance de cause pour finalement la
salir l'entreprise estime que le subit
des pertes financières des dommages sera
réputation à cause de ça donc le noeud
du dossier c'est vraiment de prouver que
Fox agit de manière intentionnelle en
pleine connaissance de cause Sidney
power qui était l'ancienne avocat de
Donald Trump et elle a dit toutes sortes
de choses farfelues en nombre dont une
thèse laquelle c'est le Venezuela qui
était derrière les machines de vote de
médiane et que le Vénus voulait
contrôler des résultats électoraux grâce
à ces machines-là et voici
Nicolas c'est un exemple parmi tant
d'autres de ce que peut dire c'est n'est
pas wall pendant des longues heures
d'entrevue c'est les zones de Fox News
Jeff amène-nous en coulisses qu'est-ce
que c'est textos qu'est-ce que ces
échanges nous disent ils nous font
comprendre sur ce qui s'est réellement
passé bon quand on lit les documents qui
ont été déposés devant la course qui est
claire c'est que les grandes têtes de
Fox News donc les dirigeants les
animateurs les personnes qui prennent
les décisions chez Passenaud savait
pertinemment que c'était faux les
allégations de de vol de l'élection on a
le correspondant politique principal de
Fuck news à Washington break d'ailleurs
déjà deux jours après l'élection il
disait lors d'une conversation écrivez
il y a absolument aucune preuve de
fraude électorale aucune par rapport aux
déclarations de seni par Wall bien les
grands animateurs connus de Fox News
tocardson et Laurine disait que elle
mentait donc casser une disait c'est ni
parois elle ment c'est complètement fou
ce qu'elle est en train de dire en
nombre il aura une grande répondait ce
n'est pas Wall est complètement cinglé
personne veut travailler avec elle et
puis l'autre une répondait ce qu'elle
dit c'est offensant pour moi donc ils
savent très pertinemment que ce que je
raconte c'est absolument faux
avant même que ce n'est pas wall rentre
en onde avec ses théories elle avait
envoyé un courriel à une des animatrice
de fortune news Maria Burty room j'ai
des preuves comme quoi de Mesnil il y a
des manigances pour voler l'élection son
courriel contenait la source de cette
information là c'est une personne qui
disait entre autres qu'elle parlait au
vent et aux fantômes et c'est là qu'elle
avait obtenu cette information-là les
réalisateurs et l'animatrice savait que
c'était ça la source d'information et
malgré ça ils lui ont permis d'aller en
nom des de raconter toutes ces choses là
ce soir là la première fois que c'est ni
parole de parler de ça sur des zones de
force news stocker Carson qui on va le
rappeler de l'animateur le plus
populaire
c'est de la foutaise complètement cette
histoire là de machine à vote truquées
donc il savait pertinemment s'il savait
pertinemment si il dit que c'est de la
foutaise pourquoi persister avec ses
mensonges en ont une publiquement mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est que après
l'élection on voit beaucoup des
supporters de Trump se met à dire que
ont été truqués à l'invitation du de
l'ex-président lui-même et puis là Fox
News commence à paniquer parce que leur
code d'écoute commence à baisser les
gens qui les supporteurs de Donald Trump
qui est habitué d'écouter Fox News là
voix Fox News ne pas parler de cette
élection truqué là il change de poste et
là on voit une panique générale le
patron de Fox Rupert qui écrit à tout le
monde dans la boîte il dit écoutez on
est en train de se faire détruire par
d'autres chaînes les gens changent de
poste et il y a carrément des
discussions dans l'interne qui disent on
est en train de perdre notre histoire
qui dit on a perdu toute crédibilité on
a perdu la confiance de notre histoire
parce que les gens veulent entendre des
histoires de l'élection volée et nous on
en parle pas sur nos ondes et ils
s'inquiète que les les parties de dans
l'autre chambre changent de poste vers
news max une autre chaîne très
conservatrice qui eux ont pas mal peu ou
pas de standard éditoriaux et force nous
y voilà un risque existentiel en disant
chez news max il raconte n'importe quoi
il rencontre mensonge ils vont venir
voler notre auditoire la présidente de
force news business donc la chaîne à
faire de Fox News le 10 carrément dans
un courriel elle dit news Max sont
définitivement du stratégie pour venir
voler notre histoire avec ses mensonges
et ses conspiration là et puis le
vice-président senior de la
programmation et de l'analytique
ce genre de couverture conspirationnelle
là c'est exactement ce que les auditeurs
un peu fâchés de force news veulent voir
donc il se rendent compte pour sauver
les codes d'école de force ils vont
devoir se tourner vers la promotion de
cette thèse à l'élection volley là qui
ne croit pas mais ils vont le mettre en
nombre pour aller retrouver leur
histoire on voit bien que le mensonge
est payant c'est ce dont se rencontrent
les directeurs les dirigeants plutôt de
Fox News et qu'est-ce qu'on doit retenir
de tout cette affaire d'abord et avant
tout mais à la lecture de ce document-là
ce qui est clair c'est que Fox News
n'est pas tant une entreprise de
nouvelles clairement donc on sait depuis
longtemps là c'est pas un secret que Fox
new une orientation éditoriale qui est
pas mal plus de droite c'était le but de
la création de Fox News qu'on voyait
comme un système médiatique qui était
plus calé à gauche qui était plus près
du parti démocrates donc c'est à la base
même de la fondation de Fox News mais là
qu'est-ce qu'on voit c'est que la
préoccupation principale de force news
ce n'est pas de présenter les nouvelles
ou de rapporter ce qui se passe dans le
monde c'est vraiment de protéger
l'entreprise elle-même de Fox News qui
est à raconter des mensonges et on le
voit que ils ont constamment mis des
bâtons dans les roues des employés de
Fox News qui a essayé de corriger les
faits et c'est arrivé plusieurs fois par
exemple il y a eu une conférence de
presse ou l'ancienne porte-parole dans
notre chambre qui est Nanny elle
racontait des fausses informations à
propos de l'élection volée
déclencher une bombe il y a même eu des
responsables du marketing chez Fox
newshock qui a appelé ça carrément une
atteinte à la marque à l'image de marque
de Fox News ce que ce que Kabuto avait
fait il y a un autre incidence ou une
journaliste de force news corriger un
tweet de dans notre Trump donc elle est
en dessous d'un de ses tweets où il
avançait toutes sortes théories encore
une fois elle a mis la bonne information
et puis là à l'intérieur de Fox News tu
as des gens comme Tokyo casting qui
disent fait la virer elle est en train
de détruire la compagnie notre image de
marque donc elle faisait tout simplement
son travail en exposant les faits qui
devraient être le travail de tout
journaliste et pour ça il est puni elle
a dû effacer son tweet parce que on
jugeait que corriger les fausses
informations de dans notre Trump exposé
la vérité c'était nuire à l'image de
marque de Fox News donc je pense qu'on
peut parler qu'il y a un virage et que
ce n'est plus un entreprise de nouvelles
puis sinon on se rend compte aussi c'est
qu'on a la démonstration qu'il y a de la
communication de la certaine
coordination entre Fox News et le parti
républicain et que Fox News est vraiment
une chaîne à vocation politique
dans les échanges on voit qu'il dit que
Fox devrait faire tout en son possible
pour aider le parti républicain à
l'emporter en Géorgie on voit aussi que
a fourni lui-même aux gendre de Donald
Trump et son proche conseiller Jared
cauchner à l'avance des publicités du
Parti démocrate donc le parti
républicain a plus stratégiquement
ajuster ses communications grâce à ça il
lui a aussi fourni des stratégies de
débats qu'entendaient employer Joe Biden
en débat donc il y a vraiment un aspect
de collaboration que la partie
républicain qui est aussi mis de la
bande là-dedans c'est tristement
ironique bon des gens qui écoutent force
news qui appuient l'ancien président
dans notre trampe accuse des médias
comme CNN comme le Newton comme le
Washington postale gauche de de
connivence avec le Parti démocrate et là
on a une preuve noire sur glace dans des
communications internes que non
seulement fuck news est prêt à mentir à
son propre histoire en pleine
connaissance de cause mais aussi de
collaborer avec un parti politique et
pourtant ce message là ne semble pas
vraiment percé
de dissonance cognitive mais les preuves
on pourrait les trouver accablantes
comment fuck news peut gagner ce match
ce duel juridique quelle est la défense
de Fox News ben ce que dit Fox new c'est
qu'il rapportait cette information là
parce qu'elle était discutée la vérité
mais qui rapportait l'information
exact et il faut noter le il y a quand
même des animateurs qui ont dit en
nombre il y a pas de preuve pour ça
nécessairement ils ont apporté quelques
nuances mais des animateurs comme
l'odeurbs appuyaient carrément ce que
disait des gens comme c'est de leurs
émissions donc Fox News dit aussi il
faut regarder la couverture d'ensemble
il y a certaines animateurs qui
questionnaient ça il y a des gens qui
rejetaient ces thèse là c'est pas tout
le monde qui faisait la promotion de
cette élection volée donc plusieurs
experts interagit dans les médias
américains disent qu'il y a une chance
que Fox new s'en sorte mais bon que le
fardeau de la preuve que des millions
reste quand même assez fort quelque
chose d'intéressant là-dedans c'est que
Fox News c'est à donner à ses mensonges
là en ondes parce qu'ils avaient peur de
perdre de l'argent en perdant de la
victoire à news max et là mais ils sont
poursuivis pour plus de 4 milliards de
dollars donc si ils perdent dans ce
cas-là est-ce que ça a value la peine de
mentir à l'arrêt du droit